hey this is presh talwalkar
a train has 11 passenger carriages
numbered from 1 to 11.
in any three consecutive passenger
carriages there are exactly 99
passengers
if there are
381 passengers in total
how many passengers are there in
carriage number nine
i think victor for the suggestion
a version of this problem appeared on
the kangaroo math exam for students age
roughly 12 to 13 years old
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
the train has 11 carriages for
passengers
write c i for the number of passengers
in carriage i
there are 381 passengers in total so the
sum of the ci's is equal to 381.
in any three consecutive passenger
carriages there are exactly 99
passengers
so c1 plus c2 plus c3 is equal to 99
then c4 plus c5 plus c6 is equal to 99
then c7 plus c8 plus c9 is equal to
ninety-nine
we can substitute these in
the sum of ninety-nine ninety-nine and
ninety-nine is equal to two hundred and
ninety-seven
the equation then becomes 297
plus c10 plus c11 is equal to 381
furthermore we know that c9 plus c10
plus c11 is equal to 99.
subtracting the second equation from the
first cancels the variables c10 and c11
this gives the following equation
297 minus c9 is equal to 381 minus 99
we simplify this equation and solve for
c9
we get c9 is equal to 15. so there are
15 passengers in carriage 9.
so that's the solution of the question
but we want to make sure that it's not
an impossible problem
so i just want to demonstrate there is a
way to distribute the passengers that
meets the original conditions
we know that c9 is equal to 15 and for
symmetrical reasons c3 is equal to 15.
so put these two quantities down
then let's say that c1 is equal to 44
because any three passenger carriages
have to have exactly 99 passengers that
means c2 is equal to 40.
from there we can just repeat this
pattern 44 40 15
44 40 15 and finally we have 44 and 40.
now 44 plus 40 plus 15 is equal to 99 so
any three consecutive passenger
carriages have a total of 99 passengers
and the sum of all these together is
equal to 381 so we've demonstrated that
some solution exists where any three
consecutive passenger carriages have
exactly 99 passengers and the total
number of passengers is equal to 381
just to show a little more general
solution
let's suppose that c1 is equal to x
then c2 would be equal to 84 minus x and
we can just repeat this pattern
so we'll be able to demonstrate that all
of these are solutions for any values of
x because any three consecutive
passenger carriages will have a total of
99 passengers and the total of all of
these is equal to 381
so this is a more general solution
what an interesting question
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on youtube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve the world's problems one video at
a time
you